Шановні колеги Дорогі українські народи
щойно завершився
історичний саміт Україна ЄС це був
перший сам під час широкомасштабної
військової агресії перший сам після того
як Україна набула статус України
кандидата члени Європейського Союзу тому
саме
важливо для нас забезпечити прогрес в
нашій інтеграції забезпечити щоб вже
цього року розпочалися при ексцес відео
переговори про вступ 23-му році
Я Хочу наголосити що одним з головних
питань які піднімалися це питання
формування незалежної судової системи і
незалежного конституційного суду
ми мали проголосувати наш закон
європейської солідарності який був
повністю узгоджений з європейськими
партнерами і замість цього
проголосували інші закони який
відштовхнув
євроінтеграцію бажано було би це зробити
до самим але зараз ми вимагаємо і
наголошуємо поставити до порядку денного
закон про конституційний суд і
проголосувати його в редакції які
відповідають рекомендаціям і
венеціанської комісії і Європейської
комісії це забезпечить єдність народу бо
90% українського народу підтримують нашу
єдність щодо вступу є ще одна позиція
яка стосується єдності і це є ставлення
до армії нас дуже обурює ситуація коли
дехто намагається зняти по 30 тисяч
гривень з українських
службовців нібито для економії бюджетних
коштів і наголошую на тому що ми не
маємо допустити щоби 30,000 грн які
військовослужбовці картку навіть з собою
на фронт не забирають або йти тереої
резерву за ці кошти купують форму
броніки шоломи то Чого не вистачало і ми
маємо захистити військовослужбовців і
позиція третя п'ята колона Ми маємо
забезпечити не лише армію де лише мову а
й Віру прийняти рішення Конституційного
Суду який забороняє використання назви
іншої як відрядження російської
православної церкви Ми маємо негайно
імплементувати цю норму Дякую Слава
Україні